alors sortez vos crayons suggestions de
cadeaux de dernière minute de beaux
livres que vous nous présenter ce soir
que se vérifie vous êtes dans l'air du
temps et là il faut la personne
on ne peut pas puis je sais que les fans
de star wars vont m'aimer de suggérer ce
titre là le retour du jedi le making off
ça vient d'arriver c'est tout chaud le
retour du jedi c'est le troisième film
en date de sortie c'est paru en 83 mais
le sixième dans toute la chronologie de
la série alors c'est parfait parce que
c'est celui qui arrive juste avant dans
l'histoire
celui qui avait juste avant le film qui
est actuellement présenté le retour du
jedi
qu'est ce que c'est c'est bien c'est
écrit par cet homme qui s'appelle
djilobodji winzeler et l'huile très très
près de l'équipe locale
il connaît beaucoup commencent à ses
frappes commence à fonctionner sur le
plateau du retour du jedi
donc c'est vraiment rémy si on veut se
replonger magnin coup ci c'est pas parce
que moi je ne suis pas jeune maniaque
mais alors là pas du tout mais j'ai
apprécié parce que justement si je veux
aller voir le film va voir vraiment une
idée de ce qui s'est passé antérieur moi
donc c'est ce que j'ai apprécié on
replonge là dedans
des anecdotes de tournage d des trucs
inédits c'est vraiment un super lira
libre avril pour tous ce bon livre oui
un très beau dit patrice assez de julie
rocheleau et de normand grégoire ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont adapté
la petite patrie l'oeuvre de claude
jasmin est apparue en 72 alors je lis
rocheleau a fait les illustrations que
les romans je suis ensuite la télésérie
cm à radio canada donc on est plongé
dans l'histoire du petit claude jasmin
qu'est ce qui se passe dans sa ville on
est dans le quartier petite patrie
à l'aube des années 40 donc c'est la
période de la seconde guerre mondiale
et c'est très fort parce que on met
vraiment en lumière tout le point de vue
rural tout ce qui se passe dans la ville
les moeurs de l'époque où si la tension
qui régnait parce qu'on entend dans la
période de la guerre des jeux de guerre
dans les ruelles
ah qu'est la religion catholique est
très présente aussi donc la petite
patrie pour ceux qui aiment s'y publiait
la pastèque une bande dessinée et
maintenant je vous transporte dans le
monde de samuel archibald de l'auteur de
arvida et d écrire la légende qui
raconte à ses petites filles avant de
s'endormir
alors c'est un livre jeunesse on est aux
cartes a nié dans la nouvelle collection
porc-épic
c'est julie rocheleau toujours là même
qui a fait la petite patrie qui a fait
les illustrations y en a quelques-unes
direct pour les enfants de 7 8 9 ans
l'histoire d'un petit gars qui est à
moitié loup à moitié humain c'est ça les
jambes et il retrouve un homme qui
s'appelle bill bilodeau l'ami des
animaux qui volait des qui va l'appuyer
parce que ce petit goal est évidemment
puisqu'il est étrange
il y un peu sauvage est victime
d'intimidation
alors il ya toute l'histoire de ce petit
garçon là et je pense que les enfants
vont trouver leur compte comme mes
parents on change complètement d'une
fleur et le là parce que beaucoup d'un
autre livre de cuisine au dessus des
livres de cuisine et celui là on est
vraiment dans le frigo des chefs c'est
de queyries salma et en guyane morse est
publié chez taschen
on entre dans le réfrigérateur de 40
grands chefs en europe
alors on explore ils ont ouvert le
réfrigérateur aux gens ce qu'ils font
jamais parce que c'est quelque chose
d'un pu priver quand même on voit
vraiment ce qu'ils mangent en famille
quand ils sont seraient reçus et donne
des recettes qui sont faciles des
recettes très accessible parce que des
fois c'est un peu complexe mais pas du
tout dans ce cas là et là je vous parle
de mon coup de coeur c'est lui les nuits
parisiennes de antoine de bec du xviiie
au 21e siècle c'est paru au seuil donc
tout ce qui se passe à paris durant la
nuit durant l'histoire ce qui a inspiré
les plus grands écrivains les peintres
les artistes notebook ladoucette a envie
de sortir à paris effectivement je dis
ah je voulais faire ma suggestion ça
mais je viens de le terminer winston sur
winston churchill bien sûr c'est écrit
par le maire de londres
c'est une biographie oui mais c'est une
analyse de l'importance qu'a eue winston
churchill dans l'histoire comme quoi un
seul homme peut faire une grande
différence
ça se lit comme un roman ça se lit super
bien c'est vraiment une suggestion un
gros groupe coeur que j'ai eus winston
boris johnson le maire de plusieurs sur
ce personnage mais celle là c'est
qu'elle est très différente beaucoup
plus fort ce qui l est
elle est personnelle johnson terme d'un
être qui l'adorent puis nous en parle
d'une manière presque affectueuse
parfois très drôle très intelligent à
lire winston claudia
or si joyeuse de l'autre côté bonaly